here we are pawn to d4
wesley so freshly chaired
goes for the queen's gambit carlson
choosing the slav
e3 many options now be sure 5 e6
where champion goes bishop g4 opts for
the pin
and plays the most simplistic setup here
gives up the bishop
puts his pawns on light squares this
line was fashionable like
12 13 years ago fell
a bit out of fashion then
i think people just concluded that the
white two bishops had to be worth
something
i started that blitz line because the
position is arguably easier to play
for black c d e d would give magnus his
beloved card spot structure
my guess is wesley wants to do something
aggressive like g4 h4
because here we played slowly like
castles rook 8 27 knight e4
black should just be fine so let's see
if magnus
is gonna castle into it he's going to
say show me the money
or if he will wait for wesley to commit
his king to either side
now he castles and wesley also castles
not in the move
for any g4 shenanigans but now black
just has a decent position
let's mention rookie 8 27 before you go
a6
try to put a knight in the middle this
bishop can regroup to d6
it's perfectly fine for black it starts
with a6 just making sure
b4 a4 b5 would take forever
proxy one okay eight
looks normal but
what do i know
here comes the rook
on to p4 anyway but now there's a
typical plan b5 knight b6 knight c4 i'm
not sure if you do it directly
or if you maybe way to move from c8 but
then a4 b yeah he plays b5
magnus knows its cults but
this knight shorted end to c4 typically
solves all of black's problems on the
queen side why is not in time here
to stop it f92 rook c8 the knight will
still come
carlson once again showing this is a
structure he understands
extremely well
can't mess with them in the call spot
i don't know what carlsbad is i guess
it's a town in the czech republic
where they had some famed tournaments i
could be wrong about
czech republic
e5 suggests in the chat i'm assuming you
mean e4
that would be a typical reaction indeed
but after e4 black can go knight b6
anyway then e5 moved the knight
or he could just take everything so i
don't think it's that tempting here
wesley goes 92
magnus c8 would be the typical way to
play here covers the pawn
now after a4 you go knight b6
there's no stopping the horsey from
making it to c4
sloppy foreskin beautiful username is
saying so jan does read the chat
always
knight c4 bishop e1 knight e4
magnus is doing fine
look at these knights
that's three
and
let's coordinate in a very nice manner
bishop h6
hinting at sacrifices
on e3 rk7 trying to keep
black sort of busy by also putting some
pressure on f7
by rook c7 the pressure is easily
dismantled even though engines might say
this is equal
maybe they no longer do these positions
are very very dangerous for white
long term if there's no play on the
queen side
slide super active
white typically ends up under some
pressure
on the king side
and of chess culture saying reminiscent
reminiscent
of nikolaj kramnik exactly those are the
classics
they call it kramnik and portish
kasparov
i forgot who this patrocian game was
against
uh yeah this is a dangerous situation
and magnus goes for broke with knight
takes e3 maybe it's not even going for
broke maybe it's just breaking through
because after f takes e3 rook takes e3
a lot of things are falling queen f1
queen takes d4 so wesley can't really
recapture rookie 2 but once again queen
d4
just seems to target lots of stuff this
knight could also just move
but yeah he goes he goes for the takes
the hot takes that's what he goes for
just winning two pawns up active pieces
another clinic in the casper structure
is so good
at this structure wesley really
shouldn't give him
give him this position after cd5